[Musique]
comment je la regarde plus petit que je
suis dans la vraie vie ça va pas du tout
bien fait sur cette vidéo activités
manuelles
j'espère que tout va bien pour vous moi
tout va bien dans la dernière vidéo on a
checké les secrets de fabrication de
pleins d'objets du quotidien
écoutez je vais pas vous mentir ça m'a
donné des idées ça me donne envie de
replonger dans ces fameuses activités
manuelles parce que j'ai découvert qu'il
ya des sortes d'ingénieurs qui font des
tuto sur youtube pour fabriquer des
trucs mais genre c'est hyper accessible
aujourd'hui chevêtres tony stark
il ya une énorme partie de ces tuto où
l'élément principal de la construction
c'est le carton je sais ça la chaîne
vous allez changer d'avis regarder je
vous mets trois quatre petits extraits
maintenant la de construction folle en
carton c'est parti c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors parce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
c'est génial mais c'est une sorte de
morceaux d'armure d'iron man mais en
carton je rigole pas on est tony stark
jusqu'au bout regardez moi ça je vous
amène tout de suite aux résultats
regardez c'est une main des portes et je
sais que vous êtes un peu choqué là on
est en vue sarsgaard et hop le pq aucun
problème ça peut le saisir quoi d'autre
que d'autres quelque chose de plus lourd
quelque chose de plus lourd le fait nous
rêver une canette une canette
ouah c'est tellement précis on peut
transposer du liquide d'un récipient un
autre me tromper mais je veux cette gêne
un peu tout de suite pour ça j'ai bien
évidemment du carton ce qui est une
chose assez simple à trouver je peux
lancer ma page facebook lanaudière
l'objectif c'est qu'on réussisse à faire
cette main et qu'à la fin de la vidéo
ont saisi des objets de plus en plus
lourd je les saisir des objets plus
lourd que lui dans la vidéo étape numéro
une
il faut tracer le contour de la main
attend quoi
mais il expliqué en mai s'annonce
houleux il a pas fait autant serment il
a tracé quoi en fait à l'écart entre les
doigts je crois logiquement gc bon ok
donc ensuite à partir de là ils tracent
des traits tout droit ok voilà combien
de centimètres les traits n'y a aucune
donnée qualques est donc en fait il fait
des très apprécié allemand doit rentrer
dans les traits dacor ac galette à
guérir gate 1
oh [ __ ] je crois je les ai pas fait
assez larges et sont dix fois plus large
les siens non mais attendez attendez je
rage déjà ça m'énerve excusez moi mais
il fait des repères il respecte toutes
là du tout pour garder aucun traîner
parallèle par rapport aux repères qu'il
a fait il a tout l'élargît est ce qu il
l'a dit à haute voix
bien sûr comment on va laisser le joueur
se démarque il est censé être ingénieur
le viewer trop lâché me bâtir un trait
j'ai fait ce trait de travers je
recommence la maison du style pu la
merde samsung s'est jamais ma faute
ok ce n'est jamais ma faute retenez bien
ça donc on recommence ok c'était combien
de lingerie mais attends je me suis
super bien sortir en fin de compte
légaré gallega voilà notre main genre
venant c'est pas dégueu on a là on
dirait audiard page facebook franchement
c'est respecter j'ai laissé un peu de
largeur tous les douars entre bien
dedans attend ça fait trente minutes que
je tourne et j'ai fait 36 secondes du
tutorat sion sur call of à l'époque donc
la cote
tous les tricks il a fait aulas la voile
ok donc le but c'est d'avoir cette belle
main tu n'as pas de prendre des parts ça
me saoule it's time to 4 fait très
attention pour ceux qui font suite aux
vraiment les plus jeunes lecteurs c'est
que si elle est parent ou un grand frère
ou une grande soeur avec vous et si
votre confrère grande soeur à plus de 18
ans il ya marqué lorraine a largué song
auteur au nom llorente c'est un an
tu fais partie de ces gens qui disent et
il s'appelle reviens je déteste que tu
ais je déteste ça se trouve ça tellement
dangereux
c'est un pas que tes droits donc je
mettais un truc en dessous moi je venais
qu'à ma table est un génie qu'est ma
table pas c'était le coup d'essai
m'annonce fois
[Musique]
des gardes et gallega les gars c'est le
démoulage selon bruce du goulasch si ça
foire maintenant je n'aurai pas le
courage je crois d'aller au bout
j'aimerais tellement en plus on a fait
beaucoup de défaites la dernière
activité manuelle ce qui ferait
tellement que oyala ok ok oh [ __ ] mais
c'est ça que j'adore c'est que quand tu
as réussi une étape tu es tellement
heureux ensuite il fait quoi il fait des
phalanges des phalanges ok c'est bon
j'ai mes doigts ainsi que mes phalanges
mec je crois que ça va marcher je rigole
pas alors là il prend un autre petit
solide attendez-vous à la cm près de
centimètres bombardier fait 11 11
donc comme ça veut dire 3 ni trop ni
veut dire faire 4 4 4 4 pour que ça se
rabattent comme ça
tain c'est propre c'est net sur ce match
messieurs dames parfait ça fait cinq
tués cinq puis 5 comme lui est ici vous
voyez je vais prédécoupés le trou je
suis réglé on n'en parle plus moi au
profil de ces duos moins satisfaisants
les gars je suis excité la vézère le
teint c'est c'est vraiment dangereux ce
truc je voulais faire ça ne l'a une fois
je suis prêt comment ça marche
je me suis fils malgré ça sans attendre
ok ok ils l'ont mais ok ok ok comme ça
fait 5 cm de longueur logiquement je
dois faire déranger
ok attendez je mets la colle j'arrive
c'est hyper satisfaisant j'arrive à 2020
dans la pure elle va [ __ ] c'est collé
bon je me suis un peu foiré sur une
mesure vous voyez c'est un petit peu en
plantes mais globalement on a nos deux
parties collet c'est moi j'ai mis une
petite rallonge mais voilà le fil
conseillera quelle est la suite mon cher
ami j'ai hâte de pouvoir saisir du pq
avec maman ok il faut couper les
paillons petits bouts et d'autres pas et
en plus grande nous toujours aucune
dimension donné ok donc ces trois
petites paille par doigt qu'on ne faut
pas que ce soit trop petits non plus on
va essayer de se faire un comme ça
c'était un grand moment dans ma carrière
de youtube donc la fin mettre de la
colle sur tout les phalanges pour coller
ensuite tous ces petits bouts ce parti
au boulot
[Musique]
[ __ ] c'est en train de sécher puis 18
on va le dire qu'apple tuto ils étaient
pressés donc il a mis toute la colle
avant de mettre les pailles mais on
aurait dû faire du cas par cas
c'est quoi cette manière de faire
complètement industrialo hockey les
doigts c'est fait ça on touche à la fin
je le sens ok on a deux sur le pouce et
ensuite là il ya des grandes en face
auquel il faut couper en plus grand port
en face
les mais ouais à peu près là on va dire
les gars le pistolet à colle c'est l'une
des choses les plus satisfaisantes que
j'ai fait vraiment j'exagère pains j'en
peux plus les gars j'ai hâte du test de
fin j'ai hâte de l'examen je vous le dis
bien tu vas faut jamais baisser sa
vigilance
j'ai peut-être un peu exagéré mais parce
que ça m'a surpris alors pour le pouce
moyenne strata ouais ok doit faire un
trou wah wah wah il fait un adapte à
paille
ça m'a gardée du bullshit j'ai besoin
que ça n'a jamais marché ce délire
[Musique]
bon le pousser marchera jamais je
préfère vous le dire ok mais que c'est
l'épreuve du fil l'épreuve
j'ai l'impression d'être fort boyard
tellement j'en chie ok il faut faire un
film plutôt long il vise plutôt large
même j'ai l'impression qu'on va dire un
film de cette longueur à peu près
[Musique]
on a les quatre fils on fait quoi mais
qu on enfile le premier et on fait un
noeud away ok war aux [ __ ]
ok c'est donc fait passer donc dans les
autres [ __ ] on touche à l'enfant j'ai
juste pas compris le noeud qui l'a fait
donc on va faire on va faire un noeud
classique genre au québec c'est vraiment
le moment de vérité
[Musique]
c'est génial c'est ça que jamais avec
ses vidéos la secal affronter est muté
fiers du tout ok je fais ça avec chaque
doigt et j'arrive à oye troisième doit
fonctionnel ok dernier doit ou la lui
l'impôt il ya ce que vous êtes prêts
pour le premier test sur le poussin mais
[ __ ] j'ai l'impression d'être tony
stark là quand il est capturé qu'il est
dans sa grotte là et qui fait une armure
offert des missiles pour les ennemis
médias si j'avais été dans cette grande
j'aurais pu faire ça j'aurais pu faire
ça c'est quoi la dernière étape watts
oh là là ok il faut calculer la longueur
la tome j'ai fait une main gauche je me
rends compte qu'à la fin c'est
incroyable c'est de très très loin
maire de très très loin la plus chiante
de tous les étapes toutes les étapes je
conjugue plus j'en suis au stade où je
ne veux plus conjuguer les mots c'est
vous dire ne poussa marche pas c'est du
fait que regarder je tire dessus se
passe rien
ok le pouce marche pas séparables sépara
spam attends je crois que c'est bon
attends je suis en train d'enfiler la
main je suis ça y est j'ai fait toutes
les boucles
on touche au but messieurs dames la main
trois niveaux de difficulté
le premier ce sera le pq le deuxième
prendre l'eau qui a dans ce récipient et
la mettre dans ce vers la 3e étape s'est
porté ce pot de mayonnaise remplie il
pèse une tonne je fais de la muscu avec
tous les soirs elle marche elle marche
vous dit rien je m'en bats les couilles
elle marche
[Musique]
j'attendais faut que je solidifie est en
train de faire de la merde je suis en
panique
non c'est une cata rien ne va c'est pas
là en fait non non non non ok j'ai mis
une barre de renfort parce que la main
et se plier à ce niveau là
[Musique]
ça tombe chaque coin par un jeu au
dernier rentre c'est toi qui m'as je
suis abattu au plat la tête du pq est
passé quoi que disent leurs agents au
l'épreuve de verser de l'eau aucun
problème regarder
[Musique]
elle marche pas en fait elle se plie si
elle se plie un nouvel endroit elle se
perd nouvel endroit mais attends mais
évidemment que c'est résolu en deux
secondes ça a donc de quoi tu me parles
mais attends mais mais elle est dingue
or la barre de renfort est en position
je suis sûr je peux arriver je rigole
même pas
[Musique]
c'est trop c'est trop c'est trop c'est
trop c'est trop c'est trop c'est trop
c'est trop c'est trop
[Musique]
ça ne marche pas parce qu'on n'a aucune
mesure l'écart entre les bouts de
plastique n'est pas de bombe bien des
phalanges qui s'articule pas les gars
j'ai tout je suis désolée de ce résultat
franchement j'ai tout donné j'ai tenté
la technique des barres de renfort est
tout rien n'a marché
c'est con mais si le gars donner la main
le nombre de centimètres entre ça par
exemple et ça et entre genre ça et ça et
ça et ça a fait clic et des données quoi
bordel c'est comme si en cuisine je te
disais tu veux de la farine la whey mais
des yeux avec mes deux bacs combien de
grammes de farine et combien d'oeuvres
jeu mais je suis un supporter a indiqué
je crois que je suis désolé oh merde
franchement j'ai tout donné c'était long
ça fait deux heures dit ce que je trouve
pour avoir fait une carton qui a woman a
pu prendre du pq je vous remercie de
sneijder à regarder cette vidéo une fois
de plus on a raté c'est quoi la dernière
fois avant le baptême où lyon n'avait
pas raté
[Musique]
allez je vous dirai bientôt je vais
quand même la garde et de manière à me
rappeler de ne plus jamais me lancer
dans un diwan sa foire quoi
[Musique]
et